SHERIFF WOULD HAVE DONE.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING US NOW FOR REACTION
IS JEFF BELL, THE PRESIDENT
OF THE BROWARD COUNTY
SHERIFF DEPUTY'S ASSOCIATION
AS WELL AS MARK FUHRMAN, WHO
IS A FORMER LAPD DETECTIVE
AND A FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
GENTLEMEN, IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
MARK, LET'S START WITH YOU.
IT WAS CHILLING TO WATCH THE
SURVEILLANCE VIDEO AND ALSO
TO LISTEN BOTH TO THE
STUDENTS' 911 CALLS AND TO
THE OLD 911 CALLS THAT CRUZ
HIMSELF MADE AND THAT CRUZ'S
CARETAKER AT THE TIME HAD
MADE.
YOUR REACTION TO THE NEW
DEVELOPMENTS?
>> WELL, WHEN I WATCHED THE
VIDEO, LAURA, THE THING THAT
REALLY STRIKES ME IS
WATCHING PETERSON LOOK AT
THE BUILDING, NOT LOOK AT
THE AREA OUTSIDE OF THE
BUILDING.
HE KNEW THE SHOTS WERE
COMING FROM THE BUILDING.
HE STOOD THERE AND HE
LISTENED FOR 4 TO 5 MINUTES
AS PROBABLY AS MANY AS 17,
18, 20 PEOPLE WERE SHOT
INSIDE.
AND HE DID NOTHING.
SO, I WATCH HIM IN THAT
VIDEO.
I DON'T THINK HE WAS
MENTALLY OR PHYSICALLY
PREPARED FOR THE JOB.
I DON'T THINK HE PROBABLY
EVER WAS.
HE LOST HIS NERVE, IF HE
EVER HAD ANY.
HE LOST IT, AND THERE IS
REALLY NO EXCUSE FOR IT
EXCEPT FOR, I THINK ONE
THING IS THERE WAS PROBABLY
A LACK OF TRAINING AND
LEADERSHIP ON THAT SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT COMING RIGHT DOWN
FROM SHERIFF ISRAEL RIGHT
DOWN TO SCOTT PETERSON.
>> Laura: JEFF, YOU HAD
SPOKEN ABOUT THIS BEFORE.
THE UTTER LACK OF TIME AND
FOCUS ON TRAINING FOR THE
EXACT TYPE OF SITUATION THAT
MARK WAS ANALYZING THERE.
ACTIVE SHOOTER, IT HAS TO BE
MUFERL MEMORY.
YOU JUST KNOW WHAT TO DO AND
YOU HAVE TO TRAIN REPEATEDLY
AND OFTEN TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND IN THE RIGHT WAY.
I MEAN, MOST PEOPLE DO.
SO, WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT
THE TRAINING AT BROWARD?
WE KNOW WHAT THE MANUAL SAYS
AND I'M GOING TO GET TO THAT
IN A MINUTE, BUT WHAT
ACTUALLY TOOK PLACE?
>> WELL, LAWYER LAURA, I
WOULD THINK IN BROWARD
COUNTY I COULD SUM THIS UP
BEST LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY.
WE PERFECT STORM COMING.
UNFORTUNATELY 17 PEOPLE LOST
THEIR LIVES IN PARKLAND THAT
DAY FOR A SERIES OF EVENTS
THAT WE CONSIDER TO BE BAD
POLICY, THE WRONG PRIORITIES
IN TRAINING, THE
POLITICIZING OF OUR POLICE
FORCES DOWN HERE, AND THE
BAD IMPLEMENTATION OF DEALS
WE MADE WITH THE SCHOOL
BOARD PROMISE PROGRAM AND
CIVIL CITATION WHAT I MEAN
BY TRAINING WHEN I GO BACK
TO THAT OUR TRAINER DOES A
WONDERFUL JOB WITH THE
LIMITED RESOURCES THEY HAVE
WITH THE BROWARD SHERIFF'S
OFFICE.
BUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS
FOCUS THE RESOURCES THAT WE
HAVE ON BETTER TACTICS AND
BETTER TRAINING.
FOR EXAMPLE, WE SPEND N
SERVICE TRAINING, 8 HOURS
MANDATORY IN SERVICE
TRAINING IN DO ESCALATION
TACTICS, AND THEN WE SPEND
ANOTHER 8 HOURS IN POLICING
TACTICS TO BE NICER TO
PEOPLE WE ARE ARRESTING.
WHEN IT COMES TIME TO
PRACTICING ON GUN RANGE AND
SCENARIOS FOUR HOURS OF
TRAINING ON THE GUN RANGE
WHERE WE MAY SQUEEZE OFF
ABOUT 150 ROUNDS AND IN TWO
HOURS OF PRACTICE WITH
SIMULATION ON THAT.
THE WRONG.
>> Laura: OH MY GOODNESS.
>> EMPHASIS PUT ON
POLITICIZING THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND NOT TRAINING
PROPERLY FOR THESE
SCENARIOS.
IT SOUGHT OF CONTROL AND WE
HAVE TO STOP.
>> Laura: THE POLITENESS
TRAINING.
MAYBE I NEED POLITENESS
HERE IS ONE SCHOOL SCREEN.
FIRST OFFICERS OR TWO
OFFICERS ON SCREEN WILL
IMMEDIATELY GO TO CONFRONT
THE SHOOTER.
MILITARY TACTICS WORK WELL
IN THIS SITUATION.
ALSO ANOTHER PART OF IT,
REMEMBER, EVERY TIME YOU
HEAR GUN SHOUT IN ACTIVE
SHOOTER INCIDENT YOU HAVE TO
BELIEVE THAT ANOTHER VICTIM
IS BEING KILLED.
MARK, YOU KNOW THIS WELL,
WITH ALL YOUR EXPERIENCE IN
LAPD SOMETHING ISN'T ADDING
UP HERE.
WE ARE GETTING REPORT AND
STILL DOING ACTUAL
INVESTIGATION ON THIS.
REPORTS FROM RETIRED
OFFICERS, MARK, WHO SAY THAT
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THE
PATRONAGE SYSTEM SCOTT
ISRAEL HAS IN EFFECT THERE,
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN PLACE
WITH INADEQUATE EXPERIENCE
TO DO THE JOBS THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING.
INADEQUATE EXPERIENCE BUT
THEY GOT A CONNECTION
BECAUSE A FRIEND OF A FRIEND
GAVE A DONATION TO HIS
CAMPAIGN.
AND IT DOESN'T LOOK GOOD.
ON THE SURFACE IT DOESN'T
LOOK GOOD.
YOUR REACTION?
>> WELL, THIS IS THE PROBLEM
WHEN YOU HAVE A POLITICIZED
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY, WHEN
YOU HAVE AN ELECTED OFFICIAL
CALLING THE SHOTS THAT QUITE
POSSIBLY IS A COMPETENT
POLICE OFFICER OR HE COULD
JUST BE A CIVILIAN THAT
BECOMES SHERIFF.
BUT, WHEN YOU START USING
NEPOTISM TO FILL YOUR RANKS
OR FAVORS OR PAYING SOMEBODY
BACK FOR THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS
OR THEIR SUPPORT DURING THE
CAMPAIGN, IT'S THE KISS OF
DEATH.
THIS IS THE LEADERSHIP
PROBLEM AND AS FAR AS WHAT
JEFF WAS SAYING ABOUT
TRAINING, LEVEL ONE OF THOSE
BEAUTIFUL GOLF COURSES DOWN
IN FLORIDA MAKE A RANGE FOR
THE OFFICERS, COUNTY WIDE, A
STATE RANGE.
THIS IS WHERE THE RUBBER
MEETS THE ROAD.
AND AS FAR AS SUSPECTS AND
BEING NICE, WHEN THEY SAY
YOU ARE UNDER ARREST, IT'S
UP TO THE SUSPECTS TO
DETERMINE WHAT HAPPENS AFTER
THAT.  IF THEY WANT TO PLAY
HARD, THEN YOU PLAY HARDER.
THAT CLASS JUST LASTED 30
SECONDS.
IT'S OVER.
YOU NEED TO FOCUS ALL YOUR
ATTENTION ON THE THREAT AND
THE DEADLY THREAT.
NOT ONLY TO THE OFFICER BUT
TO CIVILIANS AND CITIZENS
THAT ARE COMPLETELY
UNKNOWING OF THE THREAT IN
FRONT OF THEM.
OFFICERS KNOW IT AND THEY
SHOULD TRAIN FOR IT AND THEY
SHOULD TRAIN FOR SPECIFIC
INCIDENTS JUST LIKE
PARKLAND.
>> Laura: JEFF, I HAVE TO
ASK YOU ABOUT THESE CALLS
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVEN'T
FOCUSED ON BUT THAT
NOVEMBER, LATE NOVEMBER CALL
TO 911, YOU HAD NIKOLAS CRUZ
HIMSELF CALL SAYING I WAS
KICKED OUT OF THE HOUSE I'M
STAYING.
IN I GOT IN A FIGHT WITH
SOMEONE.
I WAS PUNCHING THE WALL U
AND THEN MS. DESCHAMP WHO
TOOK IN NIKOLAS CRUZ, SHE
SAID ON 11 CALL THAT WE JUST
PLAYED HE HAD HELD A GUN TO
HIS BROTHER'S HEAD BEFORE
AND TO HIS DEAD MOTHER'S
HEAD WHO HAD JUST RECENTLY
DIED.
THIS WAS NOTHING NEW FOR HIM
TO THREATEN SOMEONE TO HOLD
A GUN TO HIS HEAD.
AT THAT POINT YOU CAN BOTH
ADDRESS, THIS HOW DOES THE
POLICE NOT ACT ON THAT
KNOWING SHE SAYS HE IS GOING
TO GET A GUN AT DICK'S
SPORTING GOODS AND BASICALLY
SAID I'M VERY WORRIED ABOUT
THAT.
AND THEN SHE DOESN'T DECIDE
TO PRESS CHARGES AFTERWARDS
BECAUSE SHE FELT BAD FOR HIM
OR WHATEVER.
COULDN'T THE POLICE HAVE
ACTED RIGHT AT THAT MOMENT?
>> WELL, LAURA, DOWN HERE IN
BROWARD COUNTY, WITH THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ALL OF
THAT WAS REMOVED OUT OF OUR
HANDS WITH THE CIVIL
CITATION PROGRAM OR PROMISE
PROGRAM OUT IN THE SCHOOL OR
ARE 00 STREETS FOR THESE
MISDEMEANOR CRIMES WE DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO ARREST
THESE JUVENILES AND BRING
THEM DOWN TO THE JUVENILE
HALL.
>> Laura: 19 YEARS OLD.
NOT A JUVENILE.
>> CORRECT.
IS HE 19 NOW BUT WE HAVE
CREATED THIS SENSE OF
EMPOWERMENT TO ALLOW
MR. CRUZ AND OTHER PEOPLE
LIKE THIS TO GET TO THIS
POINT WHERE NOTHING HAS
HAPPENED IN THEIR LIFE AND
NOW WE HAVE CREATED THIS
PROBLEM.
>> RIGHT.
I GET THAT.
BUT MY POINT IS AT THAT
POINT WHEN HIS GUARDIAN
ESSENTIALLY SAYS POINTING
SON, MOTHER AND BROTHER AND
GOING TO GET A WEAPON.
COULD THE POLICE AT THAT
POINT HAVE DONE SOMETHING
AND SHOULD THEY HAVE?
YES THEY COULD HAVE IT'S A
FELONY ASSAULT WITH A DEADLY
WEAPON.
>> Laura: IT SHOULDN'T BE.
>> IT'S NOT A MISDEMEANOR.
BRANDISHING A FIREARM IS A
MISDEMEANOR BUT WHEN YOU
COUPLE WITH A THREAT, A
VERBAL THREAT THEN IT'S
ASSAULT WITH A DEADLY
WEAPON.
YOU HAVE A VICTIM IT'S
ARRESTABLE OFFENSE.
AT THE VERY LEAST YOU GET
THE WEAPONS OUT OF THE
HOUSE.
YOU ARREST THE JUVENILE.
GET HIM IN THE SYSTEM.
GET HIM IN FRONT OF A
DETECTIVE.
A SOCIAL WORKER.
GET HIM INTO JUVENILE HALL.
IF HE IS AN ADULT GET HIM
INTO JAIL AND HAVE A
DETECTIVE TALK TO HIM.
DO YOU WHAT YOU CAN.
GET ALL THE GUNS, EVERYTHING
THAT HE HAS THEN, AND YOU
TAKE IT.
>> Laura: THERE ARE SO MANY
THINGS THAT ARE RED FLAGS
HERE.
FLARES, FIREWORKS.
THE FACT THAT NONE OF THEM
ADDED UP TO AN INTERVENTION
THAT STOPPED THIS IS REALLY
STUNNING.
NONE OF THIS WAS DISCUSSED
AT THE RALLIES YESTERDAY.
IT WAS ALL DONALD TRUMP IS
BAD AND GET THE GUNS.
I MEAN, THAT'S ALL WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT.
WE WEREN'T TALKING ABOUT ANY
OF THIS.
I KNOW THE OTHER LYE LINE IS
CONVENIENT.
UP NEXT?
>> CAN I SAY SOMETHING?
>> Laura: GO AHEAD.
GO AHEAD.
>> I JUST WANT TO SAY THEY
ARE ALWAYS LOOKING FOR AN
EXCUSE NOT TO DO SOMETHING
IN CERTAIN INSTANCES.
FEMALE.
IT'S A MENTAL PATIENT.
IT'S A DRUG ADDICT.
IT'S A CHILD.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR A
REASON NOT TO DO SOMETHING,
NOT TO DO SOMETHING BECAUSE
IT'S DIFFICULT, COMPLICATED
AND TIME-CONSUMING.
>> Laura: AND THEY MIGHT GET
SUED, RIGHT?
OR THEY MIGHT GET
DISCIPLINED.
OR THEY MIGHT NOT GET
SUPPORTED BY THE SHERIFF.
THAT'S ANOTHER THING THAT
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT.
EVERYONE IS WORRIED ABOUT
GETTING SUED AND HAVING
THEIR LIVES TURNED UPSIDE
DOWN.
AND SO THE POLICE ARE --